[Music]
it's a thrill to go
into the middle of the forest and inside
a bunker and dance
the whole night and especially when it's
not allowed
insiders say berlin had two or three
illegal raves a week during lockdown
since i moved in berlin i was used to go
to secret parties
even more than going to clubs and once
we had the lock down and it was not more
possible to party
i decided to repeat what i was used to
the secret waves often have like this
festival feel about them
only there's no supplies out there
there's like nowhere to buy food or
drinks
ravers often have to walk through dark
forest for up to an hour to get to the
party
getting an ambulance in an emergency
would be a challenge
we all have to take care of each other
because we are out here alone
i think the pandemic has also in a way
like removed a lot of barriers that
traditional clubs
had especially in terms of access we are
not selecting people
everybody is welcome and we are giving
the opportunity
to do's would never get in in normal
clubs
[Music]
berlin's 226 clubs were fully closed for
15 months
until june this year i had very dark
thoughts in those times i was not
able to stay home alone
again we have to see that our mental
health is very important and for some of
us we don't really have family
and this is the only way to communicate
and to be surrounded with people that we
love
clubs are now allowed to host outdoor
parties
but ticket prices have shot up and it
can be hard to even get a ticket
so the independent raves continue
the illegal parties or whatever are
still very much
bring your negative covert test
with your name and identification and so
just as they would regulate it
in clubs they're still regulating it
outdoors
so the illegal but regulated raves look
set
to continue